are you sorry for leaving
or are you sorry for walking
for not giving me the courtesy of
telling me
both thursday's law order svu took an
emotional turn
as beloved characters olivia benson and
elliot stabler
played by marishka hargitay and
christopher maloney finally reunited on
screen
after over 10 years apart you were the
most
single most important person
in my life we merge we come together the
episode which was a special crossover
between
svu and law order's new spin-off
organized crime follows benson as she
responds to an emergency
and amid the chaos she sees this
surprise
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
it's later revealed that stabler has
been in italy working for a special task
force but when he's brought back into
the unit things
quickly go south detective all due
respect but you shouldn't even be in the
squadron right now this later turns into
stabler giving benson an emotional
apology for leaving the force without
telling her
i was afraid
[Music]
if i heard your voice i wouldn't have
been able to leave
the reunion also served as the season 22
finale
in 2018 marishka opened up to e.t about
how long she sees herself playing her
iconic tv character
if you ask me 20 years ago i never
thought i would be here
20 years later but i am and i am
fulfilled and i love my co-stars
and i am um in this incredible
collaboration uh with the with the
producers and with the writers so
i'm really enjoying it i'm just trying
to be president present and very um
and grateful so i'm thinking about this
year
about this season and how to make it the
best and then thinking a little bit
about next year
and while we keep our fingers crossed
for more stabler and benson together on
screen
christopher told et in july he'll always
cherish his relationship with marishka
as co-stars and friends i think we
value each other we have we always have
a gas i mean we're
always just breaking chops and you know
we just pick it up right where we left
off and
you know we've said it's like we don't
have she doesn't have this relationship
with anyone else i can guarantee you and
i don't have a relationship like
that i have with her with anyone else
you